récemment il s et moi avons été invités
à une autre conférence à paris
conférence avec sensiblement moins de
monde dans la salle je dirais
différentes personnes à peu près à cette
conférence
on nous a présenté toutes les deux comme
tenez vous bien un diot pour la paix un
peu comme on voit un atout puissant pour
le linge ou un parfum d'intérieur à la
vanille par exemple oui et ce n'est pas
la première fois que ça nous arrive on
nous présente souvent comme israéliennes
et palestiniennes dans ce sens là bien
sûr en même temps c'est tentant sans
raccourci qu'on a envie de faire on peut
le comprendre mais il faut je m'appelle
ines j'ai grandi à jérusalem
j'ai vécu du côté israélien et je suis
allé à l'école au collège et au lycée
avec des palestiniens
sur le papier je ne suis ni israéliennes
et palestiniennes
je suis française mais au delà du papier
je suis de jérusalem avec tout ce que ça
implique trois fois sainte problème
d'identité qui est puis sur la scène de
tête
en fait tête c'est un peu comme une
thérapie de couple on s'est rendu compte
après coup et aujourd'hui c'est un peu
la dernière séance donc on la partage
avec vous je m'appelle kenza je suis né
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée du
même côté qui naissent mais j'ai grandi
à rabat au maroc et je suis tombé dans
cette marmite bien plus tard à l'âge de
20 ans quand je suis allé passer un an à
tel aviv pour mon échange je pense mais
n'être jamais vraiment remise
complètement et je vais essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi ce soir depuis qu'on
travaille ensemble parce que maintenant
on travaille ensemble
vu qu'on ait deux femmes qu'on est
plutôt jeune qu on sourit beaucoup c'est
vrai on est souvent apparenté à quelque
chose de mignon du joli de doux de
fleury même parfois où vous y avez pensé
certains y ont pensé en tout cas nous
voyons monter comme ça de petites jeunes
femmes mais c'est pas grave ça nous
arrive vraiment souvent ça nous arrive
tellement souvent qu'on vous en veux pas
parce que
inès kenza ce soit gilles musulmane soit
peace and love un grand classique soit
vivre ensemble très tendance vivre
ensemble cette année ou encore de
kooples inez kenza en couple depuis deux
ans mais au risque de vous décevoir
encore c'est faux il ya des sujets comme
le conflit israélo-palestinien par
exemple où on est tenté de raisonner en
termes de cases binaire parce que ça
rassure ça permet de ne pas se
confronter à la complexité de la réalité
fait du bien parfois et ça permet de la
simplifier à ce titre ce sont souvent
des couples on n'a pas fait exprès de
mots qui reviennent guerre paix juste
injuste espoirs désespoir des couples de
mots qui encadre la pensée comme si
c'était soit dangereux soit impossible
d'en sortir
comme vous l'avez pu comprendre on aime
bien le danger donc on a décidé d'en
sortir en créant un espace justement
dangereux pour les certitudes on en a
même fait notre métier au final en
créant non pas un processus de paix mais
un festival décaler notre histoire à
toutes les deux la vraie histoire elle
commence à dater un petit peu on s'est
rencontré en 2007 on avait 18 ans à
l'époque et on venait commencé nos
études à sciences po
bizarrement l'année durant laquelle on
s'est vraiment rapproché c'est quand on
était loin l'une de l'autre pendant nos
échanges respectifs mois à tel aviv et
inès au caire on discutait beaucoup sur
skype on avait créé vraiment une liaison
tel-aviv le caire donc on était
potentiellement sur écoute
mais bon enfin rien de très grave une au
sujet de conversation qui n'était pas
hautement politique on va dire après ces
années des changes on est revenu à paris
pour nos masters est en bonne étudiante
on est allés à des conférences sur le
sujet encore une fois et on s'est rendu
compte comme vous sûrement que ces
conférences et débats politiques
académiques étaient pour la plupart
dogmatique et très répétitif en revenant
en france on sait aussi pris une claque
en réalisant les blocages intense que
provoquer ce conflit autour de nous au
delà et des ramifications très profonde
qu'il avait en france et qu'on avait
peut-être sous-estimé
on s'est rendu compte aussi que ces
débats maintenez les publics
tendanciellement on va dire
pro-palestiniens et pro israélien dans
leurs cases et dans leur zone de confort
qu'on a tous ces cases aujourd'hui elle
va lui
tout et n'importe quoi et c'est public
on dit pro-israélien aux pro
palestiniens ont finalement rarement
l'occasion de se croiser à paris on a
fait une petite analyse récemment qui
vaut ce qu'elle vaut
on a identifié trois positionnement qui
reviennent souvent sur le sujet le
premier mois ses mets préférés c'est les
personnes qui ont une solution à tous
les problèmes du monde
une simple s'ils ont très faim voilà
vraiment basique la leur et ça marche à
tous les coups
il y à une catégorie que moi j'aime bien
les gens qui sont dans le déni qui ne
peuvent pas regarder la réalité en face
parce qu'elle est trop laide et que ça
permet de ne pas se remettre en question
aussi connu sous le nom de la méthode de
l'autruche ou de la méthode masculine
parfois désolé messieurs
enfin les personnes qui décident de se
désintéresser d'un sujet complètement de
l'abandonner
parce que c'est trop compliqué qu'ils en
ont marre et qui y voient pas d'issue
dons qu'ils arrêtent
à partir de là on n'allait pas en rester
là bien sûr
donc on a décidé de se lancer et de
créer quelque chose de brut
dumain sans intermédiaire et sans débat
sans fin
en discutant avec des artistes en allant
voir des films en ahl au musée en temps
voilà proche du contenu artistique on
s'est rendu compte qu'il était souvent
plus pertinent et plus percutant que
tout ce qu'on avait l'habitude de nous
servir et qu'encore une fois à paris
c'était souvent un public acquis qu'ils
avaient accès on a aussi réalisé que
l'art était un moyen moins prétentieux
que d'autres qui permettait d'aborder
tous les sujets et surtout les plus
sensibles du coup un juillet 2013 on a
passé un pacte central toutes les deux
qui consistait d'abord à ne pas accepter
de cdi
ça c'était la partie facile du pacte
génération précaire oblige la nonne aux
familles dans la salle viennent de se
raidir le reste c'était surtout de ne
pas envisager de plan b pour pouvoir se
consacrer intégralement et exclusivement
à notre seul et unique plan a quitté ce
festival en août 2013 on a présenté
notre embryon de festival à nos parents
c'est une étape importante alors là ils
se sont dit qu'on était un peu tombé sur
la tête parce qu'à la base on était
censé être diplomate ou journaliste et
qu'on avait choisi l'art comme moyen de
détourner la démarche politique
classique qui bon on va dire honnêtement
n'était pas fait pour nous voilà
donc on a continué dans cette voie et en
septembre 2013 en une nuit à quatre
mains sur un google docs on a prouvé le
titre du festival on a commencé à
rédiger ce qui allait devenir notre
manifeste et dans les semaines qui ont
suivi on a commencé à contacter des
artistes sans salle sans argent et sur
facebook en décembre 2013
après s'être fait renvoyer de toutes les
salles parisiennes plus ou moins la
salle de nos rêves la bellevilloise nous
a dit oui et surtout nous a donné notre
première date pour avoir de l'argent on
a lancé une campagne de crowdfunding
parce qu'il fallait bien financer ce
festival c'est vrai qu'on a exploité nos
amis pour la campagne parce qu'on aura
mené sur la vidéo nous aider à la faire
et puis pour les donations aussi niveau
logistique on a fait comme on pouvait et
on doit dire que les artistes ont
vraiment joué le jeu et on les remercie
notamment un pianiste connu qui a
accepté de venir au festival
dans la foulée on s'est dit on va lui
proposer de jouer sur mon clavier
électrique ça fera une petite coupe
budgétaire
il a dit non au clavier mais il est
quand même venu avec son piano et il est
même revenu cette année pour raisons de
budget évidente on a dû prendre les
pires vol à nos artistes et quand je dis
les pires vol c'est des vols avec des
escales interminable puis surtout quand
il arrivait à paris
il n'arrivait pas dans une chambre
d'hôtel cosy mais on leur prêtait dans
un appartement
enfin bon après toutes ces péripéties il
en faut toujours le 24 mai 2014
vers 14h10 est né le 1er festival
israélo-palestinien artistique
indépendant et gratuit à paris
pèlerinage en décalage
t'as rien oublié maintenant j'ai un
oubli c'est très bien on savait
pertinemment qu'on se lancer sur un
terrain extrêmement glissant peut-être
un des plus glissant il y avait
certainement notre part une pointe de
provocation vous l'aurez sans doute
remarqué beaucoup de stress
aujourd'hui on est arrivé au top du là
on est bien là parce que oui on peut pas
faire mieux et parce qu'on est très têtu
ou très déterminé
on vous laissera choisir lé envie de
réaliser absolument ce qu'on avait en
tête
ce festival c'est toujours de
performances artistiques
pluridisciplinaires ont fait venir 30
artistes d'israël et de palestine
pendant deux jours à paris ce festival
on a créé toutes les deux de manière
intuitive subjective et c'est
complètement assumé à partir de nos
rencontres de nos vécus de nos histoires
de nos ambitions et nos rêves en
génération désenchantée qui rêve quand
même ce festival ce n'est pas de l'art
qui se contemple c'est de l'art qui se
vit à travers les expériences des
artistes qui viennent avec vraiment
leurs bagages leur vie à paris à la
rencontre du public parisien
ce festival c'est vraiment une
expérience intense de deux jours qu'il
laisse presque personne indifférent et
nous on aimerait vraiment que plus de
personnes qui se disent opposés à ce
festival par principe
quel que soit le principe viennent voir
ce que ça donne concrètement ce festival
c'est un espace de liberté ça c'est très
important parce qu'il est indépendant
financièrement et politiquement ce n'est
pas un festival où on essaie de faire la
paix où on demande aux artistes de venir
deux jours de s'aimer et puis de
retourner à une réalité de guerre
vraiment pas ça ce festival n'est pas la
solution à un conflit qui dure depuis
des décennies il n'a jamais prétendu
l'être et il ne le sera jamais par
contre c'est un festival qui pose plus
de questions qu'il n'apporte de réponses
dernière petite révélation en date un
ami nous a fait remarquer qu'on avait
une démarche assez camuset nos finales
et que c'était pour ça ce festival et
hénique tristement désespérée ni
bêtement naïf quand on accepte d'être
dans cette zone entre espoirs des
espoirs entre guerre et paix entre plein
d'autres choses au final il y a trois
réactions que camus juge constructive la
révolte la liberté et la passion ce
festival n'a pas changer le monde mais
lui il a changé il a grandi il attire de
plus en plus de personnes ce festival va
devenir nomades
c'est un pèlerinage après tout il va
aller dans différentes villes à londres
à new york à bruxelles et d'autres
encore et toujours
toujours avec révolte liberté
et passion merci